We're are asked to find the
cube root of negative 343.
Or another way to think
about it is some number
that when I multiply it
by itself three times,
I'm going to get negative 343.
Or another way to view
it-- this is the same thing
as negative 343
to the 1/3 power.
And the best way to
do this is to really
just try to factor this out.
So the first thing
that we could do-- so
let me just factor negative 343.
So the first thing
I'd like to do
is just factor out
the negative 1.
So this is the same thing
as negative 1 times 343.
And let's think about this.
Is this divisible by 2?
No.
Is it divisible by 3?
Let's see-- the digits do not
add up to a multiple of 3.
They add up to 10.
So it's not divisible by 3.
Not divisible by
4 since it's odd.
Not divisible by 5 because it
doesn't end with a 5 or a 0.
It's not divisible by 6, because
it's not divisible by 2 or 3.
Is it divisible by 7?
Let's check this out.
So 7 goes into 343-- 7
goes into 34 four times.
4 times 7 is 28.
34 minus 28 is going to be 6.
Bring down the 3.
7 goes into 63
exactly nine times.
So then we end up-- so 9
times 7 is 63, no remainder.
So this is going
to be 7 times 49.
And we know that 49 is the
same thing as 7 times 7.
So how can we rewrite this?
This is the same thing
as taking the cube
root of negative 1
times 7 times 7 times
7, which is the same
thing as taking the cube
root of negative 1 times the
cube root of 7 times 7 times 7.
Now, what's the cube
root of negative 1?
Well, negative 1 times itself
three times is negative 1.
So this right here
is negative 1.
You could verify it.
Negative 1 times negative
1 times negative 1
is indeed negative 1.
This becomes positive 1.
Multiply by negative 1
again, you get negative 1.
So this is negative 1.
And then this over here,
the cube root of 7 times
7 times 7-- well, that's
just going to be 7.
7 multiplied by
itself three times
gives us 7 times
7 times 7 or 343.
So it's going to
be negative 1 times
7, which is the same
thing as negative 7.
So our answer is negative 7.
And we're done.